IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
SPORT CIRCUIT.
IT HAS BEEN A GREAT DAY
FOR SPORTS FANS WITH THE NCA
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME AND THE
OPENING DAY FOR MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
SPORTS THAT DIDN'T GET
NEARLY AS MUCH ATTENTION AND
SOME CASES FOR GOOD REASON.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SOME
WEIRDO SPORTS AND FOR 250
POINTS I WANT TO YOU
ANNOUNCE WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
FIRST, FIRST, THE NORTH
AMERICAN WIFE-CARRYING
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
JADE.
>> ANOTHER BEAUTIFUL DAY
HERE AT THE DIVORCE GAMES.
>> Hardwick: YEAH, POINTS.
>> SPONSORED BY PRENUPS.
>> Hardwick: JUSTIN.
>> SHE'S LIKE, YOU THEY EVER
CARRY ME ANYWHERE NICE.
>> Hardwick: YEAH, POINTS.
>> NO, BUT --
>> Hardwick: WHY DID I GET
MARRIED?
NEXT WE HAVE A CLIP FROM NO
COMMENT TV THAT LEFT THE
ANNOUNCER SPEECHLESS.
A DIFFERENT KIND OF FOOTIE.
ENGLISH TOE WRESTLING.
THERE THEY ARE.
HOW DO YOU WIN THAT?
OH GOD.
CREEPY AMOUNT OF RELEASE
FACE.
>> HE WINS EVERY TIME.
>> Hardwick: JADE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE AN
AMBULANCE BUT WE DO HAVE A
TOE TRUCK.
>> Hardwick: HEY, NICE.
GOOD WORD PLAY.
POINTS.
NEXT UP FROM SRI LANKA, RIVER
PILLOW FIGHTING.
>> OH!
>> Hardwick: JUSTIN.
>> MAN, SRI LANKA HAS THE
WEIRDEST WAY OF PICKING A
PRESIDENT.
>> Hardwick: POINTS.
ALL RIGHT, FINALLY FROM POLAND,
THIS AQUATIC TUG-OF-WAR.
OH, OH!
OH, WHO IS GOING TO WIN? DOUG.
>> I DON'T KNOWS WHAT'S WORSE,
PARTICIPATING OR WATCHING.
>> Hardwick: POINTS.